[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the wizarding schools of
europe
however we're going to be focusing in on
one in particular
one that you may have never heard of
called of studying
now there are wizarding schools all over
the world and it just so happens that
europe
is home to four hogwarts bobaton
durmstrang
and the least known of the four koldov
sterilic
hogwarts bobaton and durmstrang are
certainly the biggest
which is why they're the main
participants in the triwizard tournament
and why they are the ones we usually
hear about but that doesn't mean
we should forget about the fourth
koldovsterinch
is the wizarding school of russia and
one of eleven schools
registered with the international
confederation of wizards
the name koldovsterich comes from the
russian words
called meaning witchcraft
and d'variets which means creator if we
overlap the two words
they form a portmanteau which means the
creator of magic
makes sense for wizarding school the
school itself is located in the hidden
part of lake lodoga
a freshwater lake located in
northwestern russia
in the vicinity of saint petersburg
though the school is russian
it's worth mentioning that they are very
welcoming of people from all countries
and will accept students from outside of
the country if a student does not live
in russia
they are assessed on their magical
abilities by teacher
the summer before the new year to see if
they are worthy of joining the school
i can't even begin to imagine how
different the harry potter story would
have been
if harry had gone to called off
studyitch instead of hogwarts
like hogwarts the school has a
protective barrier surrounding it
most likely concealment charms or the
disillusionment charm
which prevents muggles from seeing or
locating it
the school building itself is pretty
unique as it's located partially above
water
and primarily underwater the school is
quite grandiose
as the castle is huge and the colour
scheme inside is very regal
it's almost like a palace the colour
scheme inside is reflective of the house
colours of the school
as like hogwarts koldovsterich has its
own house system
however at this school the houses are
called courts
and there are three of them the colours
of these courts are
coral pink turquoise and amber which
fits well with their sort of underwater
theme
unlike at hogwarts students are sorted
into their court
in their second year and the sorting
considers both the students character
as well as their academic performance
like other wizarding schools
koldovsterich too has a school uniform
according to my source the uniforms
consist of fairly short flowing robes
in a deep navy blue with a trim of the
house color
underneath their robe they wear a white
button-up shirt with the collar coloured
in the light shade
of the house colour the last cool thing
that i want to mention about
koldovsterich is that they have their
own version of quidditch
where instead of flying on brooms they
fly on entire
uprooted trees a bunch of witches and
wizards flying around on entire trees
sounds epic to me there's not a whole
lot of information
on the school out there and that's
because it isn't in the books or the
films
but it does exist in harry potter canon
this is canon
did you know about the school let me
know in the comment section below
if i missed something please let me know
as i am still learning
just like you guys hope you enjoyed the
video until next time
nothing like a nighttime stroll to give
you ideas
[Music]
you